yes I do actually I think people are
often fascinated to know a lot of the
Iranians who are my parents age for
instance who are living in Los Angeles
many of them are conservative
Republicans many of them were big Reagan
supporters there their politics tend to
lean towards the right and I think it
took them some time to reconsider what
the whole Pahlavi dynasty was about and
why the revolution happened the way it
did you know so and then I think this
younger generation has tried to
investigate that more so and this
younger generations definitely seems
very liberal and you know left-wing and
this is an interesting question actually
well I can speak about it also
culturally especially where books are
concerned I see a major divide and what
I'm writing or what other of the
hyphenated Iranians are writing versus
what the generation before us wrote you
know there's the they tended to sort of
fall into the exotic cessation of
middle-eastern people much more easily
and much more readily I think that's why
you'll find that some of the literature
that's come out of Iran and by that I
mean the literature that's been written
abroad has not been so hard quality in
the last couple decades but I think the
- it's so to speak I think we're more
interested in style we're more
interested in art we've we've crossed
that hurdle of other Ness a little bit
and quality has become an issue again
we're not we're not being so rapidly
pursued by publishers and agents who
want to you know capitalize on the hot
new minority there's there's a little
bit of that but now because there's been
several of us there's there's room for
questions of quality and arts and that's
so I I'm very excited about this
generation you also have to remember
that you know I I just turned 30 and all
the again - its if I could say that all
the - its writing or creating art or
music they're they'll all be around my
age because most Iranians left Iran you
know 1979 80 81
right so and those of them those who
were born here or abroad would all be in
their late 20s or you know like me maybe
born in Iran but then they came here at
a young age so they can fall into the -
it phenomenon so this is a young group
of artists but there's a lot of urgency
I think and as the political climate
grows more and more precarious I think
they've had felt a need to but their art
out there but in like I said in a very
different way than the previous
generation who you know we're coming out
with works in the 80s and 90s the
urgency wasn't there and the novelty was
so I think that can sometimes create
compromised art
you